what's up everyone welcome to the life
livers academy
i'm jamie o'donnell and the purpose of
this podcast is to connect you with the
people
ideas mindsets and inspiration to
empower you to chase your dreams
unlock your potential and live life to
the fullest each day
get ready for some inspiring
conversations and incredible insights
from people who are out there living
life
having fun and dominating their chosen
path i appreciate you tuning in
now let's get this episode underway
[Music]
rightio got an old friend of mine james
marshall with me today
uh professional rugby player played for
the hurricane spent a fair bit of time
overseas and as a true
nelsonian tasman marco boy james thanks
for joining me bro really excited to
dive in and have a chat hey thanks for
having me on i've been um
just started this podcast sort of
business as well first time i've been on
the other side of the mic
so i'm really looking forward to it
let's see how we go then yeah
hey first things first uh it's a crazy
time out there at the moment for
uh all industries but particularly for
rugby
what's it been like being in camp
through the coronavirus stuff and what's
happening
uh obviously you're starting with the
hurricanes at the moment
what's it like behind the scenes what's
the feeling like we're about to get back
to playing some rugby
how has that transition been over the
last couple of months of trying to
function in professional sport but
obviously been able to do very little
yeah it was it was a mad couple of
months to be honest like
from the first sort of case we had some
sort of
preparation meetings around what how
we're going to deal with this if
it happens and then it obviously
happened and
it all went um we'll foot into full
lockdown so that was
very unique situation where all the
players are trying to
maintain their fitness skills and stuff
from their own home not
allowed not being allowed to leave the
house so it was such a unique situation
we're trying to do like
catch up with guys on zoom calls and
like keep our connections but
it was all um very sort of
yeah such a strange situation to be in
and um now
coming to the end of it it's sort of
done a real quick switch swing around
where we're
now looking at playing next weekend with
crowds and we're basically back into
business so it's been a crazy couple of
months
how have they managed to like keep the
team culture because i imagine that
as part of being like when you're
building towards a season a huge focus
obviously you want fitness and strength
and conditioning and you've got
all your tactical stuff that you're
working on but a massive part of it is
obviously building that team culture and
the connection with new guys coming in
and stuff how have they managed that
well basically they just try to keep
those connections with the zoom calls
and stuff which weren't quite the same
but i think everyone sort of missed each
other's company so much that
when we came back together that everyone
was just so happy to see each other that
um the connection we didn't lose too
much of a connection and
the way we're building towards this
first game is everyone's pretty excited
and
just really looking forward to playing
rugby because when it's taken away from
you so suddenly that
you sort of have this new appreciation
to for your job and what you're doing
yeah what's that been like for you um
obviously you're out with an injury at
the moment you've just had surgery yeah
but i think uh i've been watching a lot
of the professional
i follow a lot of professional sportsmen
online and i'm pretty fascinated in the
behind the scenes
side of things what's it been like to
stop and not have
sport like and to actually have to face
up to the fact that it's quite
vulnerable
and that there's a whole big world
outside of sport has that been like a
scary thing to face up to or how's that
been
yeah well it's something i've been
thinking about honestly throughout my
whole career like you've got these
player development
people through all your teams you have
and they're always asking you what do
you want to be when you when you finish
and
something that you don't really know and
even when you go to like sponsor
events you meet sponsor and they say oh
what do you want to do when you finish
rugby because you're not going to be
doing rugby for much longer and you're
like oh
yeah i'm i don't really know but i've
got a lot of things that i want to do
but
how do i start doing that while i'm
still playing and
well it's it's quite a awkward
transition like
there's a fair bit of anxiety around it
like making that transition and i know a
lot of people who really struggle with
it but
i mean this little break for me where
i've got 12 months
um towards the end of my career to try
different avenues
is gonna it's gonna be massive for me to
sort of um
see what i wanna do try some things and
um
if they work they work if they don't i
can i know that and i can go on to
something else but
it's definitely an area where every
rugby player
is going to come to at some point and
and
the way people deal with it's going to
be different why how well they prepare
for it
yeah yeah it's funny because i mean
obviously you've just started your
podcast as well
it feels like it's a big transition
towards athletes starting to take their
brand seriously and starting to
look at what they can leverage outside
of the game to
you know build a career for themselves
beyond that obviously arty's
uh got his podcast running and he's kind
of leading the way for a lot of the new
zealand rugby players in terms of
um he's built a clothing brand he's
doing all sorts of cool initiatives
um is it something that you feel like
people are starting to
with the rise of social media and stuff
and now having this period of time where
people have been at home
and had to stop i see tj's just launched
a card business
basketball card business do you feel
like that's kind of
been a turning point for professional
sport in terms of people now really
starting to take that on board and build
moving forward yeah i think so i don't
think people have really taken it that
seriously that building the brand
thing but like you've seen with arty and
tj like these two
they're probably two guys who have
really taken it to the next level and
um they're probably the two most popular
like famous people
rugby players in new zealand now i'd say
along with dodie and stuff but
what they've done really well is market
their brand like you say and um
they're not afraid to put things out
there and um they obviously get
huge following so and people love them
and they perform on the field so
they've got that massive advantage of of
other people who
haven't got that that they can tap into
yeah that's right
let's go back like it's funny because i
probably haven't actually sat down with
you and seen you for
i don't know maybe you know last time i
bumped into five years ago or something
in wellington yes something in ireland
bay
but um obviously we went to school
together and
uh played a little bit of rugby together
uh and
from what i remember like it was always
your dream you didn't really have
anything else that you wanted to do like
you were pretty early on you said that
you wanted to be a rugby player
is it funny looking like did you think
that you'd make it as a professional
rugby player well i always wanted to be
a rugby player but i never
really thought i'd be a rugby player i
thought i could potentially
um make a living off it travelling
around
to all sorts of like load of division
sort of things
and that was sort of um when i started
to
make the first 15 and stuff but even
from a young age i remember telling
my teacher that um she said what do you
want to do i said
i'm going to be a rugby player and
people sort of laughed and i
didn't i wasn't really sure if i
believed it or not but
she asked me if i made the under 16 a
nelson college team and i was like no i
didn't she's like oh
good luck being at rugby for having and
i was like she's right like
how am i going to be a rugby player when
i can't even make the a team of our
college and um
it was like a real moment in my mind
where i was like okay i'm gonna
give this a serious go for the next two
years if i'm not in the first fifteen
um at a hot uh one of our players in the
first fifteen
uh comes in form and then realistically
i'm not going to be able to um
not going to be able to be a
professional rugby player so um
i remember that uh christmas i asked my
mum and dad for a
joint for a gym membership for my
birthday and christmas
and i just went hard because everyone
kept saying i was too small i was a
skinny
skinny guy and um everyone would say oh
you're too small to be a professional
rugby player
you're never going to be big enough and
all strong enough and
i was like well how can i fix that so i
need to go to the gym so i went to the
gym real hard and got
got strong i was pretty i was doing some
pretty big weights for like a skinny
skinny white guy and
even throughout my whole career people
have always been like oh well how did
you get so strong but it was
it was that off season there where i
just like really wanted to
give everything or sort of not give
people a chance to
not select me so i knew the things that
they were going to say was oh you're too
small you're not strong enough so
i wanted to get bigger get strong enough
and then
find make them say something else about
me that um
for a reason for not picking me really
yeah because it was i think when we all
finished school and
everyone's sort of going off to uni and
going their different ways and stuff you
stayed in nelson and played rugby
and i don't know i can't remember
whether it's true whether i heard this
but you pretty much just spent like a
year you're just kicking goals you're
down at the gym you're just like working
your ass off after that first 15 year
to try and i don't know if you're
contracted at that point or whether
you're trying to get a contract with the
marcos
but i remember someone saying that you
were just putting in a truckload of work
to try and
get to that next level what was that
transition like from going out of
college because you're
a really good first 15 year i remember
that um
and nelson college went pretty well and
that kind of
probably put you up put you up there
like you sort of got some recognition
that yeah
what was the transition like into
professional rugby and what was it like
when you first got your contract like
your first contract
yeah so after the first 15 so i had made
the first 15 and i was kept under my
last year and
managed to start making the rec teams
and stuff so i made the
nelson bays under 18s and things and
then
um tasman offered me an academy contract
and
um there was a i also was in the frame
for new zealand under 19. so
that was like a massive turning point
for me because i was
i i was starting to get quite good
compared to the
nelson region but the thought of being
in the whole new zealand
up there with those sort of players was
sort of something i didn't
really feel like i was personally so um
when i went to those camps i was always
a little bit like whole
this is like um next level and i didn't
really believe i was good enough and i
think that sort of held me back from
making those teams a little bit
and i remember the following year where
i had quite a good year with um
tasman under 20s team and i made the
new zealand under 20s camps and there
was like a
um we had to do like a journal of what
sort of training we're doing and sending
to the coaches and i remember like going
like so hard at this i was like like you
said i was like
every day doing i was training probably
harder then than i
ever have in my career right it was like
next year when i was writing it all down
i stopped drinking i stopped um
i just fully focused on footy for like
it might have been a six month build up
to the new zealand twenties and then
i got up to camp and i was like feeling
really good but
i still wasn't sure if i was good enough
to be with these
guys who are all playing sort of itm
cuff at that stage and there's like some
big names like izzy dag and things like
that were all like
already cracked it and you're like oh
wow like i'm um
i don't really feel like i'm at that
level but i've
given it everything i could and i
actually had a really bad trial
i don't know why i think it was because
of that like i didn't really believe i
was good enough yes
um i remember sitting down with dave
rennie after the trial where he was
telling people whether it made it or not
and
um he just said to me like
i i wanted to pick you so bad because
the way you
handled it like you're a good guy and
the way you
train so hard for this i know like you
put in the best work with the journal
and all that sort of stuff and then it's
like but you just
didn't troll well enough i can't pick
you and i was like
he's alright i think you'll be a good
player you just keep working on that and
that really stuck with me because i was
like
because it was so honest that was like i
had worked hard he he recognized that
but
um i didn't play well enough and that's
that's the thing i didn't take my
opportunity so
um it was something that always sticks
with me how he believed that i could be
a pla good player but
um i didn't take my opportunity at that
time and next time you get an
opportunity it's just
so important to take the name yeah do
you
have you had because that's a really
interesting thing did you have people
between that transition like parents or
mentors who
were telling you what to do in order to
make those teams like did you have
people that like coaches and stuff that
were really
sort of helping you map out a plan or
was that drive and determination to
make it and to put in that extra work
and to stop drinking and to
really knuckle down was that on you or
did you have a good group of people
around you helping you with that well i
had the academy which was
obviously a good starting point but um
a lot of it was myself but the biggest
influence the person who's had the
biggest influence on me was andrew
goodman so yeah um he was a
pe teacher at the time at nelson college
and i went to nelson rugby football club
um he uh he basically took me under his
wing
from out of college and he would pick me
up i didn't have a car so he'd pick me
up take me to training she'd train with
me
um he yeah he was massive he had a
massive influence on me and then
obviously my brother as well who was a
bit younger but
um especially when he started um
coming out of school as well like we we
trained pretty hard together and
basically through our whole life we were
playing together like yeah yeah in some
sort of form but
yeah the way goodie um helped me
when i came out of school was massive
and what about those
because i guess when you say that
self-belief you know you sort of had
the belief when you were playing college
stuff
locally that you were good enough but
then obviously you get around guys who
have been talking i think ryan crotty
and guys like that were in the
new zealand side so there's some pretty
big names and then it's like that next
level and you're questioning whether you
belong and stuff is that something
you've battled with
throughout your whole career when you've
gone through different environments or
is that something that you've learned
from a mental perspective to like have
you got tools to deal with that because
i think
in life in general whether you go for a
new job or whether you're starting a
business or you're doing a podcast or
whatever it is
you kind of always feel inferior like
there's a bit of imposter syndrome when
you're starting something
yeah have you got tools to deal with
that or is that something that you've
just got better with
over time that's an interesting one i
think it mainly comes down to just
doing it like getting yourself like as
soon as you get that experience and you
realize that
hang on like i i can compete at this
level and
like you get so much confidence from
that so
uh and i've been listening to a lot of
things and everyone talks about just
doing it and i think that's it like as
soon as you
get out there and do it you'll realize
whether you're good enough or not pretty
quickly and if you're not
then no who cares like yeah go out there
and do it and um if you're good enough
you'll you'll
you'll find out that you're good enough
and you'll learn pretty quickly that you
can compete
cause it can be like a couple of moments
that changed that day like i was talking
to shane cameron and he said that
one of the things that helped him
throughout his entire career was early
in his career he sparred mike tyson for
i think it was six weeks or three weeks
and he went quite well against him and
like held his own against mike tyson
baddest man on the planet and
he's like they just threw down and he's
like so after that
like that just took me to another level
where i was like i can go with that guy
it means that he wouldn't kind of didn't
really have any fear going into any
other fights
you know because he'd been there and
done that and that one moment where it
was just like a chance opportunity got
called in
and did sparring with him and was a main
sparring partner but it really set him
up for
his entire career because he got so much
confidence out of it yeah
i actually remember i think i was maybe
19 and not we had an opportunity to go
down to the
crusaders there was four of us i think
it was me quinton macdonald k
pokey or he might have even been in the
team by then but
there's four of us anyway and um we went
down for a week to train with the
crusaders and
um i was pretty fit at the time i'd done
a lot of running and i've always been
pretty naturally fit like more of a like
cross-country runner than a rugby player
to be fair
and um the crusaders were doing like
this running
look i think it was like maybe a or five
laps around the field or something and
everyone sort of said just don't
overtake richie and i was like oh
[ __ ] okay because he he was but i had
the reputation that he was going to win
and
i remember just running behind richie
for like
three three or four laps and i was like
oh like i wasn't really
you knew you could take him i knew i
could take him easy i was just like too
scared to overtake him
and then khan who knew me from um tasman
he knew that i was like probably just
cruising he's like bro just
take him and then i was like okay i'm
going to go and i just took off and like
went for it because he went so far said
he couldn't like if he
tried to keep up he wouldn't and just
went and just it was a weird moment
because i was like what was holding me
back there is it like
the fear of i don't know i wasn't really
sure what it was but i just thought
yeah why am i intimidated by overtaking
what am i scared to overtake and
playing within yourself just to make
other people like feel good all that
exactly yeah it was a it was an
interesting moment for me where i just
always remember
yeah that's pretty cool it's a great
story actually
what about um your professional career
like you've traveled and you've played
all around the world
um you've been in japan most recently
back in new zealand
what are some of like what are some of
the best lessons that the game of rugby
has given you as a professional
i've been struggling with my hip for the
last couple of years which has been a
massive
thing for me um it's been quite tough
because it's
um i i want to keep playing
but my body's not really allowing it to
and i know like
mentally and stuff i'm probably my game
understanding and communication things
like that
probably at the highest level they've
ever been so i
feel i could still add things but my
body just couldn't do what
my mind was telling it so it was a real
sort of i was
like really struggling with um how to
how to go about it so
um i ended up just
just battling on probably two years
longer than i should have
with this hip which had no range i was
slow
and all these things were like sort of
getting to me like i remember doing
speed testing in japan where the whole
team was watching and
calling out everyone's times and my time
was honestly the second slowest in the
team behind a prop and i was like oh
i was supposed to go i was coming back
to super rugby this year and i was like
oh
man i i can't do this i remember
going back to my wife and saying like oh
we can't go back oh i can't run like
it's going to be embarrassing
but anyway i sort of was hoping that
when i got back here the doctors
and stuff could sort of um
fix it or like inject it or get the pain
to go away and i'll be all right to get
through the year but
once i hit my scan they saw pretty
quickly that it was
time for an operation yeah surgeon said
it was the worst they'd ever seen
so it was like it was pretty bad states
so how do you deal with that like
because what you're saying here is that
one of the things that you've learned
through rugby is that because you're up
against constant adversity right like
injuries happen
to everyone almost you're very lucky if
you don't spend time on the sidelines
yeah
uh but there's so much in there as well
like adversity is one thing and
overcoming injuries and stuff not being
picked for teams yeah
have you gone have you got any
situations like that where you've been
we've just been knocked around immensely
because you haven't been picked for
stuff
aside from that new zealand under 19s
yeah so
it's been constant throughout my career
really um
the first time was obviously when i was
trying to
um get a crack with the hurricane so i
was sort of waiting and i felt like i'd
i was ready to go and then i had an
opportunity against the highlanders
what was my i think my first start down
there and
i didn't think i played i thought i went
okay but i made a few mistakes and then
the next week obviously got dropped and
i was like damn i've missed another
opportunity
so that was sort of dwelling on my mind
and um
i remember conrad smith he was someone
who always gave me confidence he's
always someone who
i felt believed in me and he thought it
was hard done by and
things like that and hearing that from
him sort of made me
feel a bit more comfortable and then i
got another crack
a little bit later and then i ended up
staying on after that so i think people
other people can have massive influences
in those
situations but um it's how you interpret
that as well
because i was talking to a guy a couple
of weeks ago and he said he actually had
cerebral palsy and
basically was told from an early age
that he walking and talking with two
things that like
basically out of the question for him
he's always going to have really
impaired speech and he
they were like you're probably lucky to
walk and he became a professional
sprinter
and represented new zealand at the world
championships three times in the
paralympics
and is now a professional speaker and so
but his thing that he said is like
people don't understand the power of
words and he was like we throw words
around but like actually words
like one sentence that you say to
someone can change the trajectory in a
positive or negative way
depending on how they interpret it and
he was like when peop when people told
him he was constantly his entire life is
in hospital every day for the first
seven years of his life told that he
couldn't do things
so it was just she can't do this you
can't do that it was just all
limitations
and it just made him he used it as fuel
to like prove people wrong
but at the same time there was like he
had a granddad i think it was who
always said the opposite and was like
don't worry mate like regardless what
anyone says to you
this is the truth and like you can do
whatever you want and as long as you
believe and you work hard and stuff and
those words
have literally shaped his life to like
being a speaker traveling all around the
world doing all this other stuff
and like people like conrad and a few of
those guys at pivotal times goody
yeah having a few words in your ear at
the right time sounds like just had like
massive momentum towards you getting
that belief yeah and i think it
it's all about who you listen to as well
because especially now with social media
and stuff
i remember signing back with the canes
and i made the mistake of going on the
hurricanes like feed and just like it
was
abusive and i was like oh man that like
they obviously know
we're just people ripping in just
ripping him because bodie had gone and
everyone was hoping for like a big
replacement and then they got me so
everyone everyone was obviously pretty
gutted and i remember reading the feed
like oh man this is like
there's going to be some serious
pressure on me this year and with my hip
yeah
i was like because i didn't feel
comfortable like if my hip was fine i
would have probably been fine with those
comments because i would have been like
okay well
but you were feeling like i can show you
but i also felt pretty um
nervous about the whole situation i
didn't really feel like i could perform
at that level unless
um something could change with my hip so
i was i was yeah
it was quite tough and i ended up going
completely off social media because i
didn't want to read those comments again
because i knew
that that probably affected me more
because i knew myself that
um i sort of sort of felt like that as
well
so um yeah that was a tough that was
quite a tough week period so how do you
like how do you deal with that you just
obviously block it out and try and block
it out but like
are you someone who uses that as fuel or
like because people interpret and deal
with things in different ways how do you
get through those types of situations i
felt like i've always used it
as fuel before but this time i felt like
for some
probably because i didn't feel
comfortable with my hip i felt like i
didn't really use it as fuel i felt like
it
got to me a little bit because i wasn't
comfortable
so previously if someone had said
something bad about me i'd be like okay
well
i'll be i can show you like she had the
self-belief i had the self-belief that i
could do it but this time around i was
like oh i'm actually not sure if i can
compete either so
i'm not sure if it's a good signing from
the hurricane so i sort of believe you
and that's why it's affected me so yeah
well
so did you with that injury like did you
have did you keep that quiet when you
were in japan like were you just trying
to push through because
i assume that in rugby and i don't know
this but i'm assuming that
being tough is a badge of honor and
getting through and like you know you
hear of
stories of richie mccall playing on a
broken foot through the world cup and
all that type of stuff and
do you kind of naturally find yourself
falling into that were you
pushed too far or were you open about
your injuries
like i've been open about it and um so
it's been a real gradual process i had
hip surgery
um might have been 2013 for the for a
similar thing basically the same thing
on both apps
but it's slowly come back and it's just
got worse and worse
in the last two years in particular so
um
even in the uk i was having a fair bit
of problems with it
and i came back to the hurricane um
i was struggling that yeah like
it got to the point where i couldn't
even put on my rug my left rug
i couldn't touch my couldn't touch my i
couldn't get down so i remember
like before a game it was actually my
the last game in japan
boots which went up to the ankle like
the
i'm not sure why i was wearing them
because i mean
they were my only sprigs it was a real
wet day and i was like oh man i'm gonna
have to put these
these boots on and i couldn't get them
on i had to get my coach and
assistant coacher help me put my boot on
and i was like how am i playing this
and then i'm going back to the hurricane
yeah and
um i managed to get through that season
i actually discovered my shoulder
first game back and that was all caused
my hip too because i couldn't
i remember carmichael hunt running at me
and um
off the kickoff and i was so pumped to
be back wearing the canes jersey again
and
like two minutes into my return i was
like okay i'm ready for
i knew i was right he was going to run
straight at me not seen and play origin
and i was like okay massive chop tackle
here i've got to go hard and then
because i cause my hip range i can't
actually
bend and can i get down there so i had
to go into like a real
ugly position with like real bent back
head down into the ground and he
got his knee right on my shoulder and
it's just gone just popped straight out
so
i mean my hips affected my whole life
all my injuries have basically come from
my hip
throughout my career yeah but like back
to your question i was definitely honest
about it and the coaches knew that i
was struggling but they still thought i
could add enough through other areas
we had a couple of young tens as well
who they thought i could help out
and if i needed to do the job i could
step in there and
there was one week in africa when bodhi
got sick the day before a game i was
actually rooming with him
and i was supposed to play fullback but
he was outside to go into ten
and then we actually won that game i
remember the coaches saying oh
i know that you can do the job when when
we need you so
um even coming back this time even
though my hip was sore
we know we're comfortable that you can
do the job if we need you so
because you add stuff outside of that
right you've i think you're one team
team man like i don't know what the
award is but team man of the year or
whatever it is a few years
a few years in a row uh which is a
pretty amazing honour to to have you got
an awesome bunch of guys there and
obviously that culture
is such an important part so be
acknowledged for something like that
it's pretty special
but you've brought a lot more in with
your work ethic and the fact that you
turned up
i think you won all the hurricanes
fitness challenges just you know the
surfed it goes to whatever it's called
yeah man
once but but you know like
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that you you bring and it's cool that um
i guess that's a sign of a good coach is
understanding what people bring
outside of just what happens in the 80
minutes on the field right yeah
and i think one thing with me from that
point of view was um
when i wasn't selected i always tried to
do what's best for the team so
especially those first two years when i
won those awards was
i went i wasn't really playing so it was
like how can i add value
to this team by doing something else and
um
i've never been one to be too bitter
about someone else starting ahead of me
i've
always tried to um think off they're the
best part for the team that's great how
can i
how can i add something somewhere else
and that's always sort of been my
mindset and
i felt that especially at the hurricanes
because i mean that was always a dream
to pay for the hurricanes and
um to actually be in that situation i
was just like so
buzzy it was so buzzy to be there that i
was like man what can i do like how can
i make this team better so i was just
like
um did what i could and people
appreciated it and
is is that because you hear that a lot
of people say oh whatever's best for the
team like when people are dropped and
stuff like that yeah
is that genuine for a lot of people do
you reckon like most guys turning up
with their attitude or
because it feels like that's the right
thing to say yeah i would say
no like mo i'd say 90 percent like these
got everyone's so competitive
like these are the most competitive
athletes
in new zealand like they're going so
hard at each other at training
and not i don't genuinely think many
people
can say that and that's probably one
difference i i remember
otd black i feel like he was one person
who genuinely was happy
that me or bodhi was ahead of him and
because he would say
and he'd say like oh you're such a good
guy like and
i really felt like he had my backing and
he yeah right
that sort of thing so like he's one
player that i'd say would genuinely
be like that and he i feel sorry for him
actually just gotta sit behind dan and
vote
yeah i know he moves the blues for an
opportunity and vote he follows him up
there
but now he like yeah he's one player who
i'd say does do that does do that yeah
talk you've had a range of coaches over
your time
what stands out from a coaching
perspective and from like a leadership
perspective what stands out as qualities
that make a difference in a coach
because
there's you know good players turn to
coaching and they don't necessarily have
good run at coaching
then there's people who have you know
not had huge backgrounds as rugby
players who'd come in
and become great coaches in your opinion
what are the characteristics
that make someone a really good coach
yeah it's a very good question and
there's
i've had so many coaches and there's
been so many bits of
each coach which i just think oh wow
that's why that's why they're good
but then there's other areas of them
where i'm like oh they could probably
use a bit of him and yeah to make him
like the best coach but
i think it comes down to genuinely
caring about the players and
building a relationship with them is a
key um
being able to talk to them honestly um
and then just from the rugby side of
thing
not copying like i feel like the coaches
who get caught out are the ones who
have been in environment and tried to
just bring that to this environment or
like
they know the pattern that um they did
in 1999 where it was successful and
they're bringing that here now
and it just it just doesn't work where
the successful ones are the ones who are
thinking
what's something new that we can do that
no one else is doing
how can we get ahead and all these sort
of things so just staying
in front of people instead of trying to
just copy what
so if you copied like what the all black
said last year were you behind the game
you're behind the game so it's like how
what are all that's going to do this
year or what could we do this year that
is going to
have a advantage or that no one's going
to be able to defend against
what about in terms of building culture
and stuff like you've been again amongst
a whole range of different cultures and
both within rugby but also like where
you've actually lived with japan and new
zealand and places like that
what about what are the key
characteristics of building a good team
culture
well i think the best team culture i've
been involved in was the
taranaki um item cup squad when we
actually won it
and i just i because everyone came
from out of taranak a lot of the team
actually came from somewhere else and we
all sort of
um stayed in taranaki for the for the
season
everyone sort of connected and was
everyone was
um meeting up with each other outside of
training and we had just a real good
bond i felt like and everyone was
comfortable around each other they could
say what they want
whereas i know living in japan it's
obviously completely different where you
won't see
anyone else you might see the foreigners
but you won't see anyone else in the
team
outside of rugby and even in like london
it was the same sort of thing because
it's such a big place
you can't all meet up for a movie night
or something like
we were doing in taranaki where um
you you could maybe meet up with one or
two guys but any more than that it's
just
far too much of an effort so and i think
that's sort of a disadvantage for
auckland and things like that there's
bigger cities the bigger cities like
i'm even talking to billy the other day
he mentioned like he
went to catch up with one of the guys in
an hour and a half journey to go have a
coffee with them and then an hour and a
half back and it's like well
in tasman where you've got the advantage
pop down the road and
catch up with the whole crew and you get
a real sort of
good team culture from those from those
connections really so building
friendships first and foremost
yeah because it's pretty interesting it
seems like when you look at teams
scott robertson is probably someone who
springs to mind he seems like he
has the ability to no matter what team
he's coaching whether it's the
new zealand you know under 20s or
whatever or whether it's the canterbury
team or whether it's the crusaders he's
managed to just pull guys together and
feel like he doesn't get enough credit
because people say that you know he's
he's inherited the crusaders or whatever
but he actually rebuilt them like he had
a whole bunch of young guys down he was
like david haveli and people like that
who were coming through
in their first seasons and he managed to
create what looked like the tightest
team culture
and i remember i think i talked to david
briefly once out
um he was at the gym or somewhere where
i saw him and he just said like he's
he's just like one of the guys he gets
everyone on a level and he
gets to everyone's level on a personal
level and it's like
that friendship and stuff seems like
it's such a big thing but it baffles me
that that's not
just like second nature that baffles me
that like all coaches aren't doing that
or that
because it's the same in business as
well right like if you're trying to get
unity in a business environment
obviously having everyone having fun at
work and enjoying themselves and having
their mates there is such a big part of
wanting to be there and wanting to work
but it surprises me that it's not like a
big part of every culture
yeah it's interesting i haven't actually
worked with scott robinson before but
from all accounts it's the same as what
you're saying like just
really interested in wanting to know you
and being able to connect with you
so um well i've had some coaches like
that and
it definitely makes a big difference um
yeah and i i think that's a big part of
it i remember um
when mark hammock came into the
hurricane and he sort of had a bit of a
clear out of some pretty big names and
stuff but
he was he was very good at connecting
was he
yeah so he he made your partners your
wives and
family feel so welcome right and um
and it was very good at connecting with
people and then unfortunately he didn't
really get the results but i think what
he did
um sort of led up to that yeah exactly
laid the foundation for the success that
we had later on
yeah because he he came in and did all
the hard yards
and then just copped it yeah he
um because who what are some of the guys
who are some of the best leaders that
you played alongside
well conrad smith's uh probably my
favorite like
just the way he approached the game he
was smart like
um could communicate his work ethic all
these things like
he's someone you'd follow like no matter
what and yeah you trust
you trust i trusted him and everyone
trusted him
um even guys like tj now like he has a
massive influence on the hurricane so
he's probably the most influential
player that i've played with
in terms of a team environment
just what he does off the field yeah so
what why is why is he so influential is
it just like the patch because he's
obviously passionate you see that oozing
out of him yeah
but what makes him so influential he's
obviously a very good player and he
drives a lot of our
game but he's he also does a heap of
work
with the with the strategies and things
like that
um his training he's constantly out on
the field just
and p and the young guys who come and
see that and they want to they want to
be like
him he's just at the next level he's so
competitive
yeah and if someone steps out he's
probably the closest thing to
jordan like without like in terms of
that environment like that competitive
nature not just
so wanting the team to win not to that
extent of jordan like
but he's um
yeah that influential i feel yeah
because
you can sort of see it he wants to fight
for everything and like i'd imagine even
does he rough people up at training and
he'd be competitive in every environment
by the looks of it yeah he gets into a
fair bit
what about have you what's it like when
you're
running into you know like semi-finals
or the finals of the hurricanes
there was a big moment in your career
winning that um
[Music]
that year and what's it like in those
big
pressure moments are you nervous are you
excited like how do you deal with the
occasion because
you've already touched on it you said
like in those early stages of your
career
you maybe struggled to step up to the
plate when it mattered yeah but i feel
like
in those moments you probably got the
best out of yourself as a player
in a lot of those bigger moments of
super rugby and stuff
what's it like running out in those
environments and how do you cope with
that
yeah it's always there's always a bit of
anxiety
leading up to the game i'm always really
nervous leading up to it i like to get
out of the house
i hate being around my wife or family
around that the day of a big game
because it's just like oh how you
feeling how you feeling
you look you're feeling okay you're
ready to go i don't really like that
stuff so
i go into um i go to the stadium pretty
early and just
usually have a wee nap at the stadium
and stuff but um
once i'm out on the field i know i'm
fine so that's always been the thing so
um as soon as i'm on the field like you
just forget
everything and that's always been the
case but it's just how to
handle that emotion leading up to it not
overthinking it not playing the game
before you're actually out there
i'm trying to keep your thoughts
positive not negative like especially
especially at westpac i always felt like
when you look out the window and you see
the
wind and rain it's very easy to start
thinking
oh [ __ ] i'm in for a night here at
fullback like
this could be a tough night like start
getting negative thoughts like oh
i'm not actually that good under the
high ball there's going to be a lot of
them it's swirling
um these sort of thoughts so it's always
i always try and keep those thoughts
positive but
um so do you just in the mo if you have
those thoughts are you
just swatching them out for positive
stuff are you like is that something
that you consciously do or
yeah i'll just try and like yeah
basically just saying
don't worry about that like try and swap
it with something positive and then
always try and remind myself that once
i'm out on the field it's going to be
all right
like when it starts getting to the point
where all nerves are taking over like
just for me as soon as you're out in the
field you're going to be sweet so like
why are you worrying about it now sort
of thing so um
but some of those build ups to the
finals was pretty special
now there's a mess of games and like
running out when the stadium's packed
there's like
such cool feeling like there's so much
energy you get from games like that
um yeah there's there's some really cool
experiences
what do you think uh because i sort of
follows on from that but
in the moment it seems like the best
players
or the players that have the ability to
perform at their best consistently are
the ones who have like the shortest
memories
yeah like i've even just like
i've watched young kids uh and it's not
just in sport but like
who you know you miss tackle and then
they spend like the next 10 minutes
beating themselves up because they
missed a tackle and
therefore they're not present with the
plays that are happening or what's going
on and that's relevant to like business
when you make a mistake or anything else
and you spend too much time dwelling on
it instead of just putting it in the
past
but guys like richie mccor and stuff
like that seemed to be able to miss
tackle and it just didn't even
feature in their thinking is that
is that a learned skill like is that
something that you guys get taught is
that
because it's it's you have to be very
present in that moment
yeah and it's such a hard i just feel
like that's
in terms of life in general that's such
a valuable skill to have but it seems
like at professional sport
the guys that can do that all the time
are by far and above the ones who
perform most consistently yep i know 100
agree with that and it
i mean people we do have mental skills
coaches who
try and teach you this stuff but it's a
very hard thing to teach i think like
um once you're conscious of it it
obviously helps and
trying to um get those thoughts out but
i mean
probably the best person at it's bodhi
beauty barrett like
i never felt like he was ever flustered
like he could miss some
kicks or like miss attack on something
and he just would not
not look face at all and like next play
intercept try 80 meters or something
like he he was the pinnacle
at not getting flustered i felt so um
sometimes he said like
he would be like especially if he missed
a few kicks and had a
kick to win or something like i remember
one against the highlanders i think one
of them last year right on full time
sort of like
25 out right in front like the one that
everyone says oh yes
everyone's celebrating early and he's
like my legs are like shaking
you look at him and you're like man like
he's so calm
he's ice cold yeah he did because i
remember with bodhi one one of the
things
one of the most impressive things from
him was i can't remember who was
must have been the season before last
and he had a bit of a bad run
it might have been last season a bit of
a bad run and he played really poorly
and was just getting absolutely slated
in the media he'd gone from being like
the hero to the villain in like the
space of a week yeah and then they
played australia that and also i hope he
like i hope that he steps up and just
has an awesome game and shuts everyone
up i think he's got four or five tries
and just like an absolute blind but
people are so quick to jump on and
absolutely slam someone even of body
who's like so loved by the whole country
like
it can change in the space of a week
that must be really difficult to deal
with and especially at that
level obviously i haven't been in all
black but you can see
at that all black level it's just so
much more intense
like you say one or two bad games and
everyone's jumping off your ship and um
pretty quick to start begging you but
and again
like you say as soon as you have a
couple of good games or one good game
man everyone's straight back on you
loving you and
you're the talker so it's not it hasn't
been
quite that to those sort of levels uh
for me at the hurricanes and stuff i
haven't really i've always sort of been
a player who's
been under the spotlight i felt like
especially my years 2015 2016
um the years where i had a lot of
consistent game time i was
me i was basically the only non-all
black in the team or not an
international on the team so
with so many good players around me that
i was never really
in those sort of spotlights yeah i don't
if you
told someone to name the team i don't
think many people would name me in those
sort of teams so sort of that player who
i felt like put some pieces together but
was never
um up on the glory board or whatever
which i was comfortable
um do you feel like you got the most it
i do you feel like you got the most out
of yourself as a player
i think so because i was
yeah my strengths were very different to
other players and
um i could have easily had a career
where i never got an opportunity because
no coach
would have given me that chance because
it wasn't too i got my chance where
people could see what i could add and a
lot of that was around
things that people don't see like when
you watch a game like i mean as a young
kid i wouldn't like watching me as a
player like
i'm not big fast or strong like i'm one
of those guys who
works hard communication decision making
i
my basically my role at the hurricanes
was to give bodhi the best comms that i
could to make him the best player to
he could be and um i was i was happy
with that role
i loved playing with bodhi because i
knew his skill set was so good that
if i told him there's space in that
right corner it didn't have to be much
space
but i know that he could execute that
kick to hit that right corner and then
when he had hit that
i know no one else would see that what
i'd said or anything like that
no maybe not even the team but i knew
myself and i was like
those were the moments i'll be like oh
that was that was awesome play like
yeah that's cool that's really cool
because i feel like a lot of young guy
and and
it's almost like that's almost a
strength like
if you can find because everyone wants
to be big and fast and everyone wants to
be
flashy like bodhi and everyone wants to
play number 10 and yeah but if you can
early on identify those other strengths
and really build on those surely that
puts you in a better position to
actually make it yeah i think that was
one of my strengths was my was my
self-awareness
of knowing what i was good at and
knowing what i wasn't good at so
i never tried to overplay my hand by
running the ball
like i've got julian severe outside me
and i've caught the ball at fullback
i'm going to pass it to julian because i
know who i'd rather tackle me with
julian if i'm coming forward so
i mean those decisions are easy for me
and i think that's where a lot of people
get caught up in where they think that
they need their moment to and it's hard
when you're
trying to get selected or keep your spot
you feel like you need something to
prove so it's really
it can be quite hard where you think i
need to do something
but a lot of the time doing something is
not doing something or doing the right
thing and
i think that's where a lot of especially
young players get caught up in and
as soon as you have players who are
starting to think for themselves or like
just wanting to do things for their
gloria yes where you get
unstuck yeah ego's got to have a big
role in that though
massive role and you know the players
who
who have the egos and need that ball and
yeah some some are really good and some
need the ball because
yeah some some are good enough to demand
it yeah yeah if i'm demanding the ball
we're in trouble but i feel like that's
a really good point for a lot of young
guys because
you can prove so much more by like you
said self-awareness is a big part of it
playing to your strengths
but identifying who those players are
and being able to
set them up to be the best that they can
be that's an incredibly important
role to a winning team but it feels like
when you're a young guy coming through
like you're always trying to be that guy
who's a superstar but you don't
necessarily need to be
no exactly and that's sort of sort of
what i meant by that and
as soon i think every team sort of needs
players who
are willing to sacrifice themselves i i
remember probably the crusaders i've not
i never played with reuben thorne but i
heard that that's sort of like what he
was like because i mean he used to get a
real hard time from the media and stuff
everyone said he was like
mr invisible like you wouldn't see him
on the field but
everyone he who he played with loved him
so he must have been doing something
right and
i'm guessing that was sort of his sort
of role in the team is
yeah you don't make it to all that
captain being a bad player
that's cool so what about um
just go back to the injury thing for a
bit because i i feel like that's
like obviously you're experiencing it
right now but guys like uh
who you've been around a lot like uh
nihi illness gutter there's people
around you who've had some pretty bad
runs of injury and stuff what about the
mental health side of things within
rugby because i feel like
uh it's a big tough man's sport and but
you experience so much adversity like
more than more than the average person
and you're under more pressure than the
average person and everything's more
public
what about mental health within the
sport because it feels like the all
blacks turn to page
um with the world cup and the way steve
hansen dealt with it
and he kind of opened up a space where
it was all right and you know it showed
players crying in the changing rooms and
there's
felt like a bit of a shift within the
culture of new zealand rugby when steve
henson exited and
he almost made a point of that yeah
what's it what's your experience of that
because
you go through some bloody tough times
and it's very public
yeah and i i think there's actually been
a massive
change in sort of the last two years
around those sort of spaces it's
becoming more
open guys uh guys are connecting on a
more deeper level especially
i've noticed that from leaving the
hurricanes and then coming back
the two years later that guys are
actually talking about things they
weren't talking about before and
willing to catch up after a game like in
the
in the room in the hotel and get into
quite deep conversations around that
sort of stuff so
um i think in that space i think it's
there's been a massive gross growth but
um
when you talk about injuries obviously
like you said everyone gets injured at
some point and how you deal with those
injuries
is a massive part of your career because
you can either let them
get to you and come back not quite the
player you were or you can
look at it as a challenge to get better
and use those that time
for other parts or areas of your game
where you can improve so
some guys just have some rotten luck
like now he's a perfect example
yeah he's one player i just love to see
out there and um
i'm stoked that he's signed with the
highlanders i hope he can
yeah games because man he's a talent and
um
but yeah just rotten lack of injuries
and i'm not sure if you can do much
about that you can only rehab prehab so
much
and it's a contact sport you people are
going to get hurt especially when you
you're built like nearly like a
racehorse he's
like super explosive and um
yeah it's just unfortunate part of the
game really yeah it is
um just has arty it seems like
just going back to that depth of the
mental health stuff and the ability to
kind of open up those conversations have
those deeper conversations has artie
been a leader in that space for the
hurricanes because
he seems like in general he's kind of
changing the perception of a rugby
player a little bit
yeah he's been he's been massive and so
many areas of the game like
growing his brand was one thing we
talked earlier about the mental side
too like he's he's set up a group where
guys
go and have chats have these deeper
chats
um guys are loving it and he's he's been
a massive part of that shift
he and he's someone that's so
influential like if it was someone else
who started something like that
it could have the same impact exactly so
everyone respects arty everyone follows
him so
if there's something like that he's a
perfect person to
sort of open people's eyes and get him
to follow
what's your advice to a young guy out
there who
is potentially coming towards the end of
their college career now or has just
finished that college and
wants to make it a professional sport
but it's maybe having those doubts and
stuff like what what does it take to
make it
as a professional rugby player what
advice would you give to someone who's
i guess 10 years behind yeah it's a good
question i think you've got to be
willing to sacrifice
something so depending how much you want
it
like if you really want to be a
professional rugby player i
can promise you can be a professional
rugby player but you're just going to
have to make
sacrifices to get there so um
no matter on your ability obviously
ability helps but if you if you
really want it you can you can learn all
the skills to be a rugby
um you're just gonna have to sacrifice
more to get there
it might be a bit of a longer journey it
might be sort of
four or five years and not straight out
of school where
and then you start thinking oh am i
wasting my time so um
just having the belief that you're good
enough being willing to work hard make
sacrifices
and listen to the right people
yeah that's a bit the last one's a big
point
um going on to that do you believe
obviously talent is is one thing do you
genuinely believe that
you can build yourself into the person
that you need to be
how much of that is physical and how
much of that is mental as a rugby player
yeah
i genuinely think that you could you can
become a rugby player
obviously um talent if you
can't catch a tennis ball you you're
probably not going to be able to be a
professional
player like if you can't just throw it
up to yourself or things like that or if
you never played
there's a certain there's a level but if
you're a first 15 player
i believe that you could become a
professional rugby player
what about from the mindset side of
things then what like what advice would
you give
because i'm just thinking of people that
i know who who have got those
aspirations
um and i'm probably at a point where
you're about to chuck it in like i feel
like
after college there's a massive drop-off
in terms of people like if they haven't
got
named in the team then they kind of
chuck it in and go and do something else
or
the real world catches up with them
they've got to go and get jobs and it
becomes harder to
be as focused and so there's a big drop
off after like 18.
but if you can stick through that period
you give yourself a far better shot it's
like i feel like everyone sort of jumps
off the bridge at the same time yeah and
i understand that because
obviously you've got to start making
money and
you've got a life to live and you
because you can only chase your dream
for so long really but
if you are willing to make that
sacrifice and chase that dream i think
there is
you will be able to get the benefits out
of it
yeah that's it's good for anyone out
there to know because i still hope
there's still hope hey i'm gonna pull
the boots back on i reckon i've got one
season left in me
maybe okay um
i guess i'm interested to know what are
the qualities
in the exceptional players that you've
been around are there common themes that
make them
so much better we've already talked
about the ability to kind of have a
short memory and be present but like
what about things off the paddock like
goal setting and like having a vision
because i talked to
sioni found moina uh a few episodes ago
and
he said that like one of his last
seasons that he played with the warriors
was like the first time he'd ever set
goals
and he was a freak of a talent and it
just felt like
he probably didn't get the most out of
himself because just didn't focus on
getting the most out of himself
but he said as an organization they
hadn't really set goals to me who's
never been in that professional
environment that seems
absolutely insane that you wouldn't have
kind of
goals and values as a team that you're
all buying into and then as an
individual
on that side of things off the paddock
are there guys like what have you
learned on that side of things
are you someone who sets goals
vigorously and is that how you're driven
or
how does that work yeah i've always been
a big goal setter personally
and all the teams that i've been
involved in have always sort of set a
goal
so um from that sort of thing i find
that quite weird that the warriors had
never
talked about or sick um
it's hard to know what other players are
doing because you don't really talk
about it it's not like we all sit down
together and set our goals together
we do our team thing and then you sort
of do your own thing by yourself so
from that side of things i don't really
know who's um
who does why in that sort of sense but
so what do you do do you set them like
per se do you have goals for the season
do you like how
how far in advance are you thinking like
what's your process around that yeah i
usually set one for the season or set up
a few for the season and then
a few more short term depending how we
go
how i'm going and what sort of situation
obviously like
you can set a goal for the season and
then get injured and
obviously that's gone so you're just
adjusting your goals and
making little short-term goals and
things like that
do you use tools like visualization and
stuff do you visualize much
um i don't i sit down and visualize but
as i
like before a big game and things i try
and make all those visualizations
positive like
um naturally negative visualizations
come into my mind but
i try and swing them around to you know
catching that swirly high ball
yeah scoring the corner yeah it's a
funny one because it's real hard to do
it well it's a skill and it's that's
like you've got to put the repetitions
and to get good at creating those
visions but i remember when i had my
first boxing fight
all i could think about was getting
knocked out and like on the day i was
like oh my gosh
i'm gonna go on and get knocked out in
front of all my friends and family
and like it was just a constant battle
of knowing that i shouldn't be allowing
those thoughts but then like how do i
turn them off
did you get like that no i didn't
[Laughter]
but i had an injury going into it i'd
hurt my neck and so like my neck was
literally couldn't move a couple of days
before and i'd been to a chiropractor
and i had a bunch of painkillers
and i think that played into us like you
with your injury where you're like well
maybe my ability is not what it
actually should be yeah i sort of had
that but i felt i feel like as
you spend more time in it then you get
better and better and better at creating
those positive
visions do are there any guys that sort
of
because i feel like like a lot of those
top nba guys and stuff like that that
you know they speak openly about how
much they visualize and
even like law of attraction type stuff
where they're like constantly trying to
pull
the positive stuff in and they kind of
feel like time is hasn't caught up
though
are there guys in new zealand rugby who
are leading the way in that side of
things like is
or is it you just don't know because
yeah i just don't really know but i do
know that like the
most successful players are genuinely
the ones who
are out there working harder than the
other ones i mean
that's one thing that i've struggled
with my hip
throughout my career is i've felt like i
haven't
really been able to do the extra work
that i've been wanting to and
um even from probably the age
or just before my first hap operation
where i was like
is so sore that as soon as i come off
that field
to do an extra kicking session or
something it's just not worth it for the
pain that i'd have the next day on my
hip so
and in the last three years especially
like as soon as training's been finished
i've been
straight off that field and it's not
something i've liked doing but it's
something i felt like i've had to do
and i feel like i've so you sort of get
judged for being like that first guy off
the field or
um not doing your lower weights but i
just like felt like i couldn't
do it and it wasn't doing me any good
because it was doing me more harm than
good
but when you see the results that the
guys who are doing the extra work
the tjs and things like that who are
staying out for hours after training
doing whatever they're the ones who
always
will make it to that elite level and
like there's no question there's no guy
who's
stayed at training that much later and
not made it like
there's no one who given that extra
effort that worked that much harder than
everyone else and
not managed to kick on or like being
unlucky they've always seemed to be the
ones
yeah yeah it makes total sense slightly
so many stories of guys like kobe bryant
and stuff who
you know dudes rocking in three hours
before a game and he's already there
shooting from the free throw line
yeah he's got a broken arm and he's
there shooting at 5am with one arm and
just yeah how do you balance
um the pressure of professional sport
and just having a personal life like do
you
because i feel i feel like even with
guys like you're talking about guys like
tj and stuff who are on all the time
they're doing all the extras
obviously just so passionate about it
how do you
what's the balance there between that
because i feel like having
a good quality of life off the field
makes you a good player on the field as
well yeah
and i think having a family was a
massive thing for me like as soon as i
had we had
ollie who's now four that was a massive
thing for me to just switch off
go home and see him play with him and um
being a dad's just been like it's been
one thing that i've always wanted to be
and i just love it so much that um i
just love playing with the kids
i'm out on the go i'm struggling at the
moment in the crutches the boys don't
really know what's going on but
um yeah just as soon as i'm back from
training and stuff
i'm out with them and just fully
switched off yeah that's cool
it's important that what um
i guess just sort of i guess wrapping up
we've been talking for a few while but
just
for anyone out there who
anyone particularly young people out
there who it doesn't have to be about
professional sport but
got dreams and ambitions i feel like a
lot of the time
you're they're squashed pretty early
like high school the careers advisors
like those types of things are always
putting a ceiling on what you can and
can't achieve
and i the reason i like sitting down and
talking with people like you is because
your dream was to be a rugby player you
went out and you're living your dream as
a professional
player and that's the i don't think
there's anything better that you can go
out and do
than fulfill what you always wanted to
do
but i do feel like it's it's you're
going against the grain when you're
doing it which i don't think should be
the way
what's your advice to people out there
who are trying to make life decisions at
the moment or have maybe got some
ambitions doesn't have to be sporting
wise
um from having lived the last 10 years
you know doing what you wanted to do
yeah well i had so many people tell me
that
i'm you'll never be able to be a rugby
player and if i like when
i said earlier when i said it people
would laugh and
i'm not really sure i guess it's just
don't listen to them or listen to the
right people listen
listen to yourself if you believe that
you can do it just go out there and do
it and like give it a
give it a full crack like have no
regrets like if you really want to do
something just
go out and then do it and then see what
happens like as soon as you start
questioning yourself or
second guessing then that's when things
are gonna get harder
yeah what's the highlight of you have
you got a highlight of your career
um obviously winning the super rugby is
probably the biggest thing but also
um winning the item cut with taranaki
was that was probably the best i felt
after a game like
that when i when we won the super rugby
i'm not really sure i was expecting to
have a heap of like emotion of like
happiness but it was
i didn't really get it it was sort of
just um relief more than anything
probably because
we didn't win the year before lost to
the highlanders and that was pretty
gutting but
um when we beat the lions it was
when that game finished i don't know it
was just sort of like oh thank god that
that's happened and we've won it and
it's over and it wasn't really like a
yes this is awesome it was like uh oh
yeah i'm not really sure why i was
expecting a lot more a lot more out of
it
when we won it with taranaki obviously
that was against tasman and that was
the most intense sort of so much
niggle abuse and like
chat on the field that that was
i've never been that fired up in a game
in my
i probably had it i had a shocking game
i was just like so emotionally wound up
and
there was so much niggle going on
there's so much chat or like
abuse and it was specifically towards
you because
x tasman or like what um definitely
towards me
but i'm not sure if it was it was
probably a little bit to do excessive i
knew a lot of them my brother was
playing he didn't talk to me for a
couple of weeks
some things said which you'll probably
regret but
yeah and just remember like everyone
just into it like they remember a
penalty early on the game and everyone
was just like coming in like
trying to fight and stuff everyone was
so in the red and the crowd was so
massive and on top of us that
there's just so much energy and i think
everyone's emotions and that whole game
got the better of them but
it came out on the right side yeah that
was pretty cool you were captain
for that as well yeah yeah that's pretty
awesome
do you when you're in those moment
because like the emotion thing that's
pretty important thing to touch on as
well because
when you're running hot like that you
don't necessarily get the best out of
yourself yeah
and i feel like i've probably haven't
played as well as i could have in finals
before and i you see
some players who like you said are just
so consistent
in those key big moments and they've
just got their emotions so under control
and
you see it in league with guys like cam
smith jonathan
where they're just they don't ever look
they're just on one level
exactly and they like not it doesn't
look like they're angry or
ever too emotional about it and
just looks like another game or every
everyday game where
my mindset definitely wasn't there like
i was playing in the final in front of
30 000 people just like so wired up
right
i took it yeah i think i took a fair bit
of learning out of that just to
try and keep it as another game it is
just enough
but um there's just a bit more writing
on it
what's your perspective on you're moving
into sort of another phase or
setting up for another phase of your
life now where potentially you might
play a bit more rugby but you
obviously we've covered and with your
injury and everything you're sort of
looking at the next
next phase what does that look like for
you you've talked about coaching and
stuff like that do you
do you have ambitions to be in coaching
i've always felt like coaching sort of
been my calling more than
playing to be honest and um
i if i didn't have a family and a wife i
would 100
be going down the coaching dream chasing
that but the thing with the coaching
is that you're still living that rugby
player lifestyle where you're moving
around and i mean we have
as a family we haven't stayed in the
same place longer than a year and a half
and that was when we moved to london
and every six months other than that
we've been moving around so we've moved
to italy
now centering wellington taranaki and
things like that
japan wellington japan wellington so as
a family
my voice starts school next year we're
so keen to just settle down somewhere
and find a base so
if it wasn't for that i'd love to be a
coach but
um i just i'm not going to chase the
coaching dream by moving around if a
coaching job opportunity came up
where i was and i'd 100 percent jump at
that and would love to do that but
um if anyone from tesla marcus is
listening
sign them up yeah i guess
values change over time and exactly and
it's
the priority now i've had my time living
my dream and
doing my things so i feel like now's the
time to
let the kids settle down and live a good
life and
stop moving them around because it does
get pretty hard on them yeah nice
you're a good man jimmy i appreciate it
chatting man and just want to wish you
all the best for your rehab
uh and for whatever's next i personally
hope that you get back out on the field
never run around i've always enjoyed
supporting you and watching you play
um i know that having known you from
when we're at high school that rugby was
always the dream so it's pretty awesome
to chat to you
uh and that sort of full circle thing
and it's just
yeah i hope that the next phase goes
really well for you bro yeah cheers mate
thanks for having me on and hopefully we
can have sort of the 19 combo next time
that was probably the chubbiest number
nine you've ever seen
cheers mate so there you have it guys
that was the interview with james
marshall
that was a really cool conversation for
me because james and i were friends at
high school
and we played a lot of rugby together in
college and it was always his dream to
go out there and make it as a
professional rugby player so
to sort of get the opportunity to sit
down with him and have that conversation
10 years down the track and reflect on
his
journey from college right through to
playing professional rugby here in new
zealand and also abroad
it's just a really cool conversation
i've got a lot of respect for anyone who
goes out there and chases their dream
and there's a lot of valuable insights
in there for any young guy in particular
who wants to go out there and make it in
professional sports so
i hope you found value in that if you
did please share it out with anyone that
you think would enjoy listening to it
uh and feel free to follow james on
instagram it's at james marshall
he's actually just launched his own
podcast called the what a lad podcast
which is james sitting down and having
conversations with some of the best lads
that he's met through his playing days
and talking about all things
professional sport and also diving into
some of the antics they get up to off
the field so
give that one a listen and check that
one out like i said share that out with
anyone that you think would get value
from it
and i look forward to connecting with
you in the next episode
[Music]
you